at the end of the day i mean the
cultures are you know are are are
different but at the end of the day you
find out that you can you you know you
can speak to you can speak to everyone
and that we all have you know the the
similarities
and
and so i guess i i i was surprised to
see that even the cultures are very
different we as as people as
as human beings are very are very
similar in the end of the day
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
talking about israel and japan and
everything in between meet anatila
cerney managing partner of aristogora vc
anada's co-founder and managing partner
at aristogra vc
prior to establishing aristogora anat
was vice president head of the asia
practice at discount capital
underwriting and subsidiary of discount
bank
prior to that anat led the asia practice
at one of israel's largest law firms
anat has experience in advising
asian-based investors and leading
investment transactions in the israeli
tech market anat also has broad
familiarity in asian capital markets
assisting israeli tech companies tapping
into these markets for funding and for
exposure to asian partnerships anat
holds a bachelor's of law and a
bachelors of eastern asian studies from
the hebrew university of jerusalem
she is also a graduate of beijing
language and cultural university where
she majored in chinese studies
anat
cherny welcome to 20 minute leaders now
from tel aviv but i guess usually it's
sometimes from asia sometimes from
israel right
yeah yeah
but uh now from tel aviv
not from tel aviv anat
you you've been on the israel asia
ecosystem for for the last 12 years and
the last two years have been the
managing partner of arista gora venture
capital uh with with investors in asia
but also in the israeli ecosystem so
really interesting bridge here and and
what i'm really curious in these 20
minutes or so is to you know try to
understand a little bit about your
career and and how you ended up
making this transition to
to sort of encapsulate both ecosystems
and then what's happening today and what
can we as entrepreneurs learn about the
this merging of ecosystems so that we
can um so we can work with it so anat
thank you very much for joining me
yes thank you michael i'm happy to be
here
so uh yes i'm one of the founders and
managing partner at aristogawa vc it's
an early stage vc fund operating in
israel
and i've been in the vc and investment
tech investment ecosystem for the last
several years but even before that i was
very keen on the israel asia
space and this is something that my
career is uh uh you know based upon so
actually i i studied uh my ba at the
hebrew university i studied law and
eastern asian studies and immediately
after i graduated i relocated to
beijing china
there i studied a chinese in one of the
universities
and i worked as an analyst in a chinese
business consulting firm i was the only
non-chinese employee in that firm
and at that time i was mainly mainly
engaged in mobile payments uh
space
it was around 2010 2011 and china was
one of the pioneers in mobile payment
solutions
um so i had a lot of work
in that respect and by the way even
today if you ever got to
visit china or one of the big cities in
china uh you know there are beggars in
the street and even the beggars in the
street they're using their wecha wichita
digital wallet
in order to
you know to to to to claim for for money
from people in the streets so yeah just
uh um
funny fact so after uh two years in
china i i came back to israel i spent a
few years
in one of israel's leading law firm as a
lawyer in the tech department i did tech
and m a deals
with chinese and singaporean based
investors who invested in the israeli
tech ecosystem
even at that time i was visiting china
and singapore quite often and
brought
dozens of chinese investors to israel to
invest in
you know israeli startups
and after a few years i decided i want
to move to the investment
investment space so i joined this con
capital
um as a vp and the head of the asia
practice
and in that time i was doing investments
from you know pre-seed to to pre-ipo in
various segments from food tech to cyber
etc etc
with asian based
typically institutional investors but
also uh you know private investors
who are looking to get
diversification and exposure to the
israeli tech ecosystem
i was working quite a lot with japanese
investors and i really come to the
realization that there is a huge demand
from the japanese
uh side
to get exposed to the israeli tech and
on the other hand
you know many israeli companies
uh look at the asia market as uh you
know as one of their target markets and
it's quite difficult to access uh the
asian market especially the japanese
market
and it requires expertise and this is
actually the background to the
establishment of aristotle ovc
so give me you know a
thirty thousand feet in the air what's
happening today in terms of the
relationship between israel and asia
specifically when it comes to the
startup ecosystem and venture capital
what are the different avenues in which
in which entrepreneurs from either
places are dealing with investors from
either place
yeah okay so
yeah i think that like 10 years ago
israeli companies started looking not
only on the u.s market as a target
market for uh you know from business
point of view but also on asian markets
and i
roughly up until 2015 china uh had a
very important uh a place in the
ecosystem as an investor
as a business partner for israeli
companies but
i would say that sometime
after 2015
two things happened first there was an
internal regulation within china
that
concerns uh investments outside of china
and basically restricts uh investments
outside of china
and second of all you know the the u.s
china trade war is obviously impacting
uh the ecosystem
and basically japan became you know uh a
good uh candidate for collaboration
between israel and and japan and
actually next year israel and japan are
going to celebrate uh 70 years of
diplomatic uh
relations
um
and even even though we have a long
history of diplomatic relations um
only in the last few years the uh
relationship the business relationship
between the two countries
got closer and i think that one of the
reasons for that is that uh the mutual
visits of the governments of the state
of israel and japan in 2015
and with japan it's really a matter of
you know getting the support of the
government in order for the business
community to to follow and i think that
that's what happened and you know uh
just last year in uh 2021
a
roughly 3 billion u.s dollars of
investments came from japan uh to israel
yeah which is a huge amount and it's
actually uh two times the amount of uh
2020.
um
and so uh we see this collaboration
growing and you know typically japanese
investors like to invest in later stage
uh they like to invest in something that
they can grasp
and for us that there is agora vc um
we're quite unique in that sense because
we really invest in pure early stage
companies in the seed and the pre-seed
stage
what is some of the added value that
that is coming from specifically now
japan with aristocracy that we're
looking at israeli startups you know the
capital is not is no longer the the most
critical piece of the of the investment
obviously of course it is but but there
are still now many other layers of an
investment process that that come to a
decision for a joint collaboration
between a startup and an investor what
what what are some of the things that
are not trivial that are coming from the
asian
asian market and investors that startups
here in tel aviv or israel in general
can utilize
yeah well first of all i always say that
for us it's you know it's an added value
that we can bring to our portfolio
companies with respect to the japanese
market specifically in the asian market
in general but you know most of our
companies their initial market is the us
and that's very natural but in terms of
the asian market you know it's it's a
market that you really have to know
and you have to understand how it works
and and specifically with the with the
japanese market
um collaborations with japanese partners
is something that takes time uh you need
to be very patient uh uh you need to
have a very uh long-term vision and for
us israelis we're very anxious uh to do
things uh fast and we think fast and we
want processes to move fast and so
sometimes it's uh it's you know it's it
creates some kind of conflict and this
is the reason that i think it's
important to have someone in the middle
who is able to understand you know both
sides the israeli side and the japanese
side and is able to just you know be the
middleman in this uh in this story
obviously the japanese market is a huge
market and for many companies such as
you know
robotic oriented companies uh
companies in the space of silver tech uh
um this market is really relevant
right so what how does an entrepreneur
know
in today's world whether it is relevant
to
be looking at at not just asia as a
market for selling the product but also
as a market for investing in the product
what are some things that today's
entrepreneurs can do to really
understand whether there is an added
value there that would go both ways
yeah i think it's you know it's a matter
of of you know the timing where you
explore this opportunity
on the one hand entrepreneurs should not
uh go into the japanese market at a very
early stage of the
you know of the of the life of the
company because as i said it takes time
it takes resources it takes the you know
the management time and so you should
really do it when when when you're at a
stage that is suitable on the other hand
as i said it takes time so we have to
find the right timing in order to to
explore this uh to explore this uh uh
opportunity
right and so the steps of actually
approaching an investment opportunity in
this world is it the same way that one
would approach an investment opportunity
with the traditional vc in israel
yeah so so for us i mean we're a
financial you know we're financial uh uh
pure financial vc we're not a a
corporate we see uh in any way we're not
you know strategic
so
i i assume yes it's uh it's the same
approach that you i mean that any
entrepreneur would take with any global
uh
or israeli vc
but but i am assuming that there are
some subtle perhaps differences in the
culture especially as it is in the life
cycle of working with an investor
investment firm that is also based in
asia there are some cultural nuances
that one might want to adjust to
to to be able that to have everybody
feel comfortable what are some things
that you know i should keep in mind as
as i'm forming relationships with people
in asia
yeah
okay so one thing you have to bear in
mind is to be
i mean you have to be really uh polite
and and patient and it's not always
there you know uh
the right moment to to say jokes
sometimes it's uh not considered as a
joke in the you know in the other side
um
for us as a you know as a vc that is has
a strong orientation uh in japan
i mean uh uh um
our partners are very uh have worked you
know globally and in the us and in
europe for many years and so these type
of nuances are less felt but when when
when someone is working you know with a
hardcore japanese corporate and you know
you really have to
to be patient
to be polite to have
the long-term
vision i would say these are the
important things to bear in mind
amazing anat you've been in this for for
12 years but but i i wondered as before
how did you even get to beijing in the
first place how did you end up yourself
forming this you know sort of dual
citizenship non-diplomatic but still
dual citizenship at least in and at
heart
for
these two continents that are so vastly
different
yeah
so i guess you know ever since i was a
child i was very interested in in
cultures and in different cultures and
in understanding different people
and from a very young age i i realized
that languages is some kind of a gateway
to understanding uh people
and so in junior high i you know i
studied arabic and then i was chosen to
go with uh
a delegation of three israelis and three
palestinians from javon to norway to uh
to have some uh you know discussions
about uh the situation in israel and
uh about the conflict and uh um
you know later on at the university i
studied chinese and then
you know i felt i really wanted to
experience in first-hand you know the
the people and and the mindset and so i
i took my stuff and relocated there uh
to beijing and so um
yeah
this is this is the way i started my you
know started my career with with asia
what surprised you along this journey so
far it's a pretty pretty unique journey
and i'm sure full of surprises all
around but what's really been surprising
for you
in these last few years
uh you know in at the end of the day i
mean the cultures are you know are
are are different but at the end of the
day you find out that you can you you
know you can speak to you can speak to
everyone and that we all have you know
the the similarities and uh
um and so i guess i i i was surprised to
see that even the cultures are very
different we as as people as
as human beings are very are very
similar in the end of the day
take me back a little bit and not to to
the founding of aristo gora
how what is it like starting a fund with
investors in asia what kind of what what
kind of
sort of work do you need to do together
with them
so that there is an alignment of
understanding of what's happening here
in the israeli ecosystem how how do
investments get made how do startups
think and feel what kind of work did you
have to do to sort of align everybody
around the table
yeah so that's a that's a great question
uh because you know
most of the
japanese lp's that we have in our fund
were not familiar with the israeli tech
ecosystem before uh investing in
aristotle vc
um but actually i spent several years
together with my partner
in japan you know
introducing to the israeli ecosystem uh
to the israeli startups and most
importantly to the israeli early stage
startups because
you know
typically japanese investors
are used to to you know exploring
investments in later stage companies and
so
looking at the early stage ecosystem is
something that is really new to them and
so we had to do a lot of work in that
sense
of introducing the challenges of
investing in early stage which is
completely different uh from investing
in in later stage
um companies and on top of that you know
we had to do a road show in the you know
in the peak of of you know uh kavid
which is kind of difficult uh because in
japanese you do business uh uh
you know you meet in person
and so you know uh zoom and and and
virtual uh you know video calls is uh
is challenging but uh but doable after
all
i love it
what did what did you enjoy most
about your work so far here because
again i'm you know investments are
awesome startups are awesome
working with asia is amazing but what
really is the most fun that you get out
of your work today
you know i feel very i feel very lucky
because i wake up in the morning and i
and i do what i really
like to do the most and you know
naturally i'm a very curious person i i
love to learn and i feel that every day
i learn so much because i get to meet
uh you know bright people who are
starting um you know
innovative startups with super
interesting technologies and at the end
of the day this is
this is the work that i that i like to
do
is it the the investing the supporting
them afterwards the both
yeah
i mean the investment part is i mean
it's it's it's an important part because
this is you know there is kind of a
short
term period where you really have to
um
get to know uh you know the the prospect
uh you know the the candidate for
investment and so it's a really like
it's a really intense uh time where you
meet and you get to know the
and you get to know the company but
mainly you get to know the the people
that are leading
these startups and i think that this is
a
this is the most uh you know interesting
uh thing in the process
i love it and not i really want to thank
you for for coming here i think that you
know the work that you're doing with
aristo gora
in with asia in general but you know
it's it's very interesting because it's
it's different you know there's at the
end you know our ecosystem is so wide
and so incredible and and there's so
many opportunities around the world and
i and i just love it when people come
and they bridge the gaps between the
different geographies but not just
geographies also culturally
and and at the end it's just a it's an
amazing contribution to our ecosystem
here in general and and i got to
to
meet aristotle in different ways by now
and i know that it's such a such an
awesome vc so thank you very much for
spending the time here with me and stay
safe and stay healthy
[Music]